all right guys
bang bang i've got the original oh geez
of this podcast back together we'll get
to that story in a second
but uh i've got jason and mike
co-founders of block works here thanks
so much for doing this guys
yeah thanks for having us all right
let's jump right into your background
uh where did you guys meet and how did
you start block works
yeah um we met at uh we both went to
emory
uh emory university down in atlanta um
so
we both went to school down there um
we came to new york together uh mike and
i were kind of our only two friends who
didn't go and uh
do the traditional path of working in
banking like most of our other friends
did and i was it
most of our friends studied business and
mike was a i think a classics guy or a
psychic
major i was a history major so we were
kind of our two friends who were fixing
around mike was working consulting i
worked um
at this venture firm and then went into
uh it's like software company but
anyways
block works was a kind of a funny
founding story with block works i went
to uh
i went to this crypto event on a sunday
i i've been pretty into bitcoin since i
lived
in budapest hungary actually weirdly
enough and i went to this blockchain
event with
bomb you know amanda gutterman um
consensus
amanda was speaking uh talking about
like why ethereum was going to change
the world
and before the event there was this like
side hustle consulting event
about how to how to build a consulting
firm so i show up at this event it's
like 1 p.m on a sunday
i learn how to create a side hustle and
consulting 2 p.m i go hear amanda
gutterman blow my mind about how crazy
ethereum is
i come back to the apartment i sit mike
down for a real serious conversation i
say look buddy we're uh
i'm launching a consulting firm to help
fortune 500s
understand ethereum and blockchain you
want in
you're my friend who has consulting
knowledge and uh i'll let you yeah
and i was like uh yeah that sounds like
a really stupid idea
no offense there jason but i mean
honestly like i had worked at a really
small like a boutique consulting firm
and the thing there is you're selling
your your brand and trust and all that
kind of stuff and it's really hard to do
if you don't have a name
especially if you're two like 23 year
old guys which is what we were at the
time
but that was the beginning for like we
were the only two within our friend
group that really got bitten by the
bitcoin bug
so that was kind of we took the very
traditional route of you know we were
kind of passing podcasts back and forth
with one another we were passing
articles getting plugged into twitter
all the super classic things that
everyone does when they first get into
the space
and the light bulb didn't really go off
until we actually started to go to
new york and we went to a couple of them
but it all really connected at this one
event that
it was an expensive event we each paid
like 200 bucks to get in and we were
just super pissed off
because the event sucked um you know
you're like watching these
people on stage um and we're just kind
of sitting there and we're like
oh my god and everyone in this room paid
the same amount of money however
organized this event
actually made and what we were going to
do was we were going to host events to
help us
build that brand image or that kind of
name and trust in space
that would eventually lead to consulting
but that's how we got started as an
events company and so
uh we have a bunch of hilarious stories
i think that we're gonna talk about
today
uh one of them probably starts with um
the event that i spoke at was this the
first one you guys ever threw or was
this one of the early ones you threw
this was one of the early ones so we
hosted one in february uh
basically mike and i would wake up mike
and i had a full-time job so we'd wake
up at 4am every single day
we we spent no money on marketing for
the event we still three years later
spent
zero dollars on marketing to this day
and uh we'd wake up at 4am we'd each
message about
300 people on linkedin between 4 and 6
a.m
out of the 10 000 people we messaged
about 220 showed up
everyone paid like 50 bucks a pot then
we hadn't then we quit our jobs like the
psychos we were after kind of one step
through one event we had this plan
we're like cleaning out yeah we're gonna
do this for like 12 months our salaries
are going to support us
blah blah blah one month later we both
quit our jobs
mike pulls trigger quits his event says
you got to join me i quit my
i quit my job and um we hosted may event
may 10th about 10 days after we both
quit our jobs
lost money that were complete idiots um
and then the third event we had was june
28
2018 i think it was called like capital
raising in the age of blockchain or
something and
we had some guys from like grayscale and
genesis speak and i think you were in
maybe japan or you were overseas but we
had
we emailed you the funny story here is
we emailed you a dozen times
we were ruthless about cold emailing and
cold calling back then
i scraped your email somehow and emailed
you like 10 11 12 times on the 12th
email
you responded you said look guys i don't
know who you are
i don't know who you are but if i come
speak at your event will you stop
emailing me
you said sure absolutely mr pabliano
and so you show with paulina we have
this like
like bad little uh you know venue
in chinatown you show up with paulina
you speak we auto subscribe you to our
newsletter
and uh the rest is history yeah so
i don't even know if you remember this
part you called us back into your office
the next day after that to talk about
stuff
and that was that was like a pivotal
moment for
me and jason you know getting that email
from you and it was something really
innocuous it was like so
so what are you guys doing like as a
business like what are you really doing
here
and you know we got that email and we
were like oh man he wants to invest
i looked at mike pompeo i knew it he
wants to invest
poppy in those goes guys i uh i like the
newsletter what are you guys up to i
look at mike i go
he wants to buy us no doubt no doubt
no i i the uh the thing i remember is
when
uh i went to the event it was a little
you know
sketchy part of town uh of chinatown
there and when i was
walking into the event you know like go
through this like real
like weird-looking place and like go
upstairs or whatever and there was like
you know
a second there i was like i might be
walking into like a complete scam these
guys might try to kill me
uh and then i got just like oh okay this
is like a nice thing there's like food
here they must know what they're doing
uh and then a bunch of people came like
i don't know it's like 200 300 people
whatever it was so i was like
like maybe they actually do know what
they're doing yeah look we've i mean
since the beginning we've always tried
to help kind of the investor crowd
understand crypto but at the beginning
we had to do some some kind of
ridiculous
things to uh to get folks there like at
the beginning
mike would just ruthlessly call cold
call family office investors to try to
get them to show up and
i would buy ubers for these people to
make sure that they actually showed up
and we'd have ubers pick them up at
their door so
pulled a whole bunch of tricks to get
people to get there but at the end of
the day i mean people showed up and
um yeah and then we launched the pot and
then you kind of called us in and
launched the podcast with you and
that kind of kicked off the whole
business so so the part uh the
story you guys have told me since then
is uh
i don't remember how a podcast came i
don't think i even knew really what a
podcast was
and at some point it was like oh we
should like do a podcast and i was like
i don't got time for that
and you guys are like what like
basically if
uh all you do is you just walk in the
room record the conversation and leave
and everything else is done like would
you do it
and i was like sure and i thought that
you guys like knew what you were doing
all this stuff because yeah we could do
that
and then later on i found out that you
guys like went home and googled like
how do you create a podcast like what is
a microphone or
whatever i mean i literally never opened
garage band in my life and i
taught myself on youtube how to learn
garageband overnight we're like yeah
pomp we got this we have
i was like we have a graphic designer
who can do this we pulled up like 99
designs
and uh mike reached out to a college
buddy who did music and we made uh
made the jingle so that's that's when
people hear the pomp podcaster what used
to be off the train that's
that's the uh kind of origin story so
what's the biggest takeaway from how you
guys got started in terms of
like there's a ton of ridiculous things
but uh
you survived and eventually thrived like
what was your biggest takeaways uh
starting
i mean there's a there's a lot of
takeaways but honestly i think one of
the big takeaways especially running a
bootstrap business is just to do stuff
and when you do stuff you kind of create
your own luck honestly like
that was a good a great example that is
just us kind of linking up with you
you know we hosted a couple of events
before that they were like good we made
a little bit of money
lost a little bit of money but nothing
really happened until you know meeting
you
opened up this whole new line of
business for us in the form of podcasts
um and that lesson has replicated itself
a bunch of ways but basically if you
just kind of put yourself
out there and do a whole bunch of
different stuff not everything is going
to work but they're going to be some
things that work
super super well so you kind of end up
creating your own luck
just by trying a whole bunch of
different things and doing stuff yeah
mine is but the thing i
would say is just ruthlessly cold call
and cold email people
and just don't take no for an answer at
the beginning when you're launching a
business
um i mean if you if we stopped emailing
you after those first 11 emails
right who knows what would have happened
and i mean we saw that so many times
like
i don't know i remember we sold one time
we sold a family office dinner we said
15 family offices were gonna show up
it was the night before we had two
attending out of 15
and mike scraped every single family
office
investor in new york city and cold
called every single one and we got 18 to
show up
so i don't know it's just be ruthless
with with your outreach uh
and good things everyone wanted family
offices back then i had no idea what a
family office was everyone's like we
want these family offices we want these
family
honestly the only reason we successfully
got him is if we had known how hard it
was to get in touch
we just never would have even tried um
but yeah those were those are the early
days
it worked uh so you guys built out a
pretty large business
um there's podcasts there's ad sales uh
you've got a newsletter
um and then you decided like hey
we want to kind of take a step back and
uh
really be intentional about what we do
moving going forward uh
the name went from block works group to
just block works you know a big rebrand
there
uh and uh and you're now relaunching
um as uh this financial media company
i think you're doing is like really
interesting so talk through a little bit
just about the
uh kind of focus on financial media
and specifically helping uh
institutional investors learn about
digital assets
yeah maybe i'll take kind of the the
two-year evolution of what
got us to here then mike you can kind of
talk to the editorial side of things but
i mean just to fill the listeners in
after we launched that podcast with you
since then we've taken
we have 19 more podcasts in our network
we work with folks like we've built
shows with like charlie shrem and we
worked with
melton de mears and joe carlson and we
studied billionaires and ted cities of
capital allocators and peter mccormick
so we've got
the largest podcast network in the space
one of the largest podcast networks in
financial media in general our events
business grew from like these 6 to 10
p.m events
to you know large-scale conferences uh
that we hosted in places like new york
and chicago and london and so we
we built you know kind of a a very
successful
events and and podcasting business over
the last few years that does one thing
really well which is
help investors understand digital assets
and
what you're talking about now is you
know on january 12th we've just
i'm not sure when this podcast is coming
out maybe january 12th or 13th we've
we've just launched our editorial
business
um and maybe mike mike is kind of our
operating editor in chief right now so
he can talk to that side
yeah so basically the neat we figured
this out pretty quickly even when we
were just hosting the the tinier events
but
ever since we've moved into the space
there has not been a good source of
knowledge for
institutions in in crypto and it's been
really interesting to watch even over
the course of the last five or six
months when you see the types of people
that are getting involved in this space
the kind of paul tudor jones's and the
stanley druckenmillers of the world
right that's one group of institutions
that's kind of the macro hedge funds
but as this space continues to grow and
onboard new cohorts of people
they're going to be some kind of like
the corporate people at the enterprise
blockchain people who are going to be
want to be interested in how is this
going to help my business then there's
going to be a whole
other group of people like kind of the
tech people the developer focus crowd
but then there's this whole big crowd of
people which is the finance crowd and
that gets grouped in our space we
just call them the institutions but it's
really a whole bunch of different groups
of people
right it's kind of the macro finance
guys like the hedge fund traders
but there are also rias and kind of
wealth management
there are investment banks commercial
banks insurance companies
all these people are paying attention to
crypto now and they want to
learn more and you know
the space up until this point has been
entirely retail
right and so the me many of the media
companies that exist
built their audience you know built
their company serving the audience
that existed which was at that time a
retail audience so there really hasn't
been much opportunity until now
to actually build a media company that
is exclusively focused on
serving that new cohort of people that
are going to come in
and that's what we're really focused on
doing on the editorial side of things
so yeah that's a little bit about our
site and
when you think about like the existing
uh media
and kind of content bitcoin and crypto
are very unique
i think in that uh there's people who
are creating content on twitter
instagram with memes uh reddit uh
private whatsapp groups kind of like
there's all this like user generated
content
in the community and then you've got uh
crypto native
uh organizations like the coin desks the
blocks
um you know and many others uh and then
you've got like the traditional
folks um who are the cnbcs the
bloomberg's
the yahoo finances that are trying to
cover this from more of a traditional
viewpoint and then you've got this like
explosion of
podcasts and youtube channels and so
there's all this content but what it
sounds like you guys are really saying
is like all that content is focused on
educating the retail sector really what
you guys are doing is more
almost b2b type media where you're going
to go and try
um to create content that is valuable to
these institutional investors and help
them get up to speed is that a fair way
to kind of
look at the competitive landscape if you
will and how
do you guys think you're going to fit
into this totally
yeah i mean even like anecdotally if you
listen to what michael saylor was saying
there's a bunch of pot he's been on the
kind of podcast circuit recently and
he describes what it was like educating
his board
about making that investment decision
and literally if you listen to them he
was like i was sending them youtube
videos
that is that is incredible first of all
the bet that he made is incredible but
the fact that a
you know a board of a public company had
to learn about this space and probably
the biggest investment that company has
ever made
through youtube videos is absolutely
nuts and it shows you how early though
like that's insane
and to even use like a more micro
example like let's say you're
an ria or something like that right and
you're thinking about you
care about one thing how am i going to
build my business right so you've got
all these clients now that are asking
you
bitcoin just hit 40 000. what is this
should i be putting this in my portfolio
why isn't it already in my portfolio why
can't you talk to me about this
so what they're thinking is i got to
understand what this stuff is
and i got to understand how i'm going to
get paid off it how is this going to fit
into my existing infrastructure
so you can kind of imagine the
frustration of someone like that who
genuinely wants to learn
and get onboarded and a they get
bombarded in this twitter community as
like have fun staying poor
but all right which is you know it is
what it is but you can imagine the
frustration they get that on twitter
and then they go to a lot of these these
sites and it's like
really deep dives into defy and zk
snarks and all that stuff and they just
kind of throw their hands up and say
this isn't for me you know i don't care
about this doesn't connect with my life
so really when we say we're building an
institutionally focused brand
you gotta really put yourself in the
shoes of these people and try to
understand
why are they caring about the space and
that's the guiding light for content
i mean pomp you speak to these folks all
day long i just pulled up one of our you
know
another crypto media company that one of
the ones that you just mentioned
let me read these three articles trade
santa is giving away christmas gifts
reef finance debuts as the first polka
dot project on binance launch pool
cyber vein announces proof of
contribution consensus mechanism
i'm a 50 year old gray haired hedge fund
manager looking to allocate two percent
to bitcoin
i'm throwing my hands up and i'm closing
that page and telling my investment
committee that we have no interest in
bitcoin
right but but they're so but but there's
so many different aspects
of this space that just don't get
covered right from the asset managers
to how bitcoin's intertwined with you
know things like central banking
um you know fed activity it's just not
getting covered from an institutional
light
and that's the next extension of our
business is this editorial arm
got it and so when you guys think about
the body of work that goes into this is
this
going to be audio written video a
combination like how do you think about
the actual editorial output of what
you're going to have
i think it's a combination of all those
things i think when it comes to content
it has to conform to a specific medium
so when it comes to things like podcast
podcasts are really good for what we're
doing
now like long form uh conversations
expositions kind of deep dives on
specific things that's great that that
works really well on podcasts
um written serves a different need
written is you're kind of
covering a certain space right and
people kind of go there for more
information right so you got to find a
way to just cover a certain specific
space
um and deliver just short form kind of
better better content
um and then i think video is another
really interesting medium as well
but i think overall with the mix we're
kind of i mean jason can talk a little
bit
more about the reasons why why we
decided to play in certain mediums but
um the overall guiding light of the
content the audience that you're serving
is the same but it has to be different
depending on the medium
so on the editorial side of things palm
so we've just doubled the size of the
company in the last 30 days
a few of the and we're hiring for a lot
of
more a lot more roles for any uh
listeners out there who are interested
in joining a crypto media
company but we um mike is kind of our
operating editor-in-chief he's just
built a team we've hired
kind of a senior person from real vision
we've hired reporters from places like
uh american banker bloomberg
an ex-coin desk employee so yeah we're
quickly building the editorial team but
again everything is focused on helping
that
more traditional investor understand the
space
got it and so when you think through the
types of stories like give us an exam
an example of uh what a hedge fund
manager or somebody at an institution
uh would come to you to read about so
they're not reading about cyber chain
or whatever other crazy thing uh sushi
swap
and you know kind of all the really
nuanced highly speculative but yet
highly
uh experimental and potentially highly
innovative things
um but just two in the weeds what is the
type of content that
they'll be reading yeah so we kind of
segment our content into four different
buckets
um one is asset management so literally
just covering the space of asset
management within crypto
um it's such an interesting it's such an
interesting space right the people that
are managing money
it's still like we've talked about
before so small right but the returns
that these people are generating now are
crazy and they've got some really
interesting strategies and they're just
really interesting people
so one is actually just covering the
space of asset management
within crypto uh the other is finance
and financial services right so that's
really focusing on some of those
institutions we were talking about
before
maybe they're not if if they're not
buying large chunks of
uh bitcoin but maybe it's like an
investment bank that's buying a crypto
company to start a trading desk
or maybe it's a bank or large asset
manager that's kind of moving into
custody
basically covering existing financial
services and how they're starting to
play in this space
um three is macro so there are jason
kind of mentioned this before but there
are some topics
like central banking and cbdc's are a
really good one that that's a really
great overlay in between
obviously digital currencies is an idea
that was born in crypto
but that cuts right to the heart of kind
of traditional finance
right uh because it's central banking so
there are areas around kind of interest
rates and currencies and central banking
and monetary policy
um that really intersect uh with crypto
um and then finally the last one is a
strong markets focus right so really
focusing on things like market structure
what traders are doing
all that kind of good stuff got it and
how did you guys think about like from a
business perspective there's so many
media models today
right there's uh subscription there's
advertising
um there's literally like lead
generation
there is affiliates ecommerce
yeah yeah like how did you guys think of
or how
are you thinking about monetizing uh the
business moving forward
yeah um so the first thing that we did
is we looked at every single
media company right and this is
everything from hodinki with watches to
the wall street journal to
bloomberg which is more of a data
company to things like morning brew
we looked at every single media company
that our business has always been based
around sponsorships and advertisements
right so we have a really simple
business
we we help investors understand crypto
by giving them
information and insights we build an
audience that really trusts us
and we allow brands to tap into that
audience some of our big clients are
like fidelity digital assets coinbase
block fi
cme group they come to us because they
want to meet investors interested in
crypto
uh and we'll allow them to tap into that
audience through advertisements and
sponsorships
we looked at subscription models we
looked at affiliate media models
basically our conclusion was
if you look at kind of the evolution of
digital media over the last i don't know
10 20 years
really decade i guess i'd call it b2c
media
raised a bunch of money and basically
got their lunch eaten
by social media big companies like vox
and buzzfeed made
huge bets that they would leverage
social media to
build their platforms what they didn't
understand though is that the value
accrued to social media and that it
didn't actually accrue
to these digital media companies so what
you've seen is basically the evolution
of
two two different types of media
companies b2b
media companies right one of our
advisors is a man by the name of sean
griffey
he runs industry dive really niche media
company
from an outsider point of view inside
the company they do 40 50 60 million in
revenue and they're profitable
right so that's kind of b2b media
companies that serve their audience
that's what we are on the kind of
more like webinar newsletter our
editorial front is a b2b media company
that monetizes through sponsorships and
ads
and then on the podcast front um you
look at the podcast space
wondering just got bought for what 300
million by amazon
gimlet got bought by for 200 million by
spotify
the podcast space is booming right now
and so what we're trying to do is
basically
leverage talent to sit at the talon is
sitting at the center
of of this b2b media company which we
think is a really unique model
um and we think that every media company
in the world needs to have a talent
strategy
uh no different than how cnbc has andrew
ross orkin and how vox had
kara swisher right and the pop podcast
has pumped up
and the pop podcast
so uh how do you guys feel or see
the uh institutional kind of openness
uh really changing the sentiment
changing obviously we're talking about
kind of
your strategy as to how you're gonna
move forward uh i tend to agree that
this is really smart for you to do and
will be highly successful
um but the sentiment in 2018 is a little
bit different than sentiment 2019
than 20 and like now at 2021 it feels
like everyone is
you know using hashtag bitcoin on
twitter uh they want to tell you about
the how they bought their first bitcoin
in 2018
and uh you know they're ready to rock
and roll so like how
have you guys seen that sentiment shift
over time
yeah i mean it's funny there's
people think about uh fomo a lot of
people use that as like a dirty word
right um but but it's kind of not right
and and
i know you've talked about this as well
that a lot of these guys they had all
the time and opportunity in the world to
buy bitcoin when it was
three thousand five thousand whatever it
was and they didn't and
um there's kind of a reflexive property
in bitcoin where as the price goes up
um you know the network actually gets
ends up getting more secure you've got
more people participating it's actually
more valuable
and i think you're starting to see that
take effect in a big way
and one of the other problems with
bitcoin overall is that it's always been
kind of too small
like scale has always been a huge
problem for these guys where it's like
okay
you know i'm a 10 billion dollar asset
manager i want to put 100 million
dollars to work the space was just
straight up
way too small so i think right now i
mean as we're talking
right before this bitcoin hit 40k so i
think there definitely is
uh some danger of being kind of euphoric
settlement that's not making a comment
on the price or where i think it might
go but
i definitely think emotions are a little
bit high uh in the space overall
um so that probably has to end at some
point but
i really do think um you know some of
the best info that you can get
on this the kind of the sentiment gauge
is actually not listening to people in
crypto
but listening to the more macro people
and if you tune in to some of the macro
podcasts right so that's kind of the
grant williams show that's macro voices
that's masters in business you know six
months ago
bitcoin was a dirty word and every one
of these podcasts every one of these
guys is talking about it and they're
talking about it in sophisticated ways
they're using good arguments and they're
open-minded and to me that's a really
powerful way to measure the sentiment of
the overall space
and is it fair to say that we're now at
a point where uh
every single institutional investor is
like i gotta have a bitcoin strategy and
they're actually going and
allocating yeah i mean i i can't speak
to every single one
but i think so it's a powerful tool
right in the same way
and the same social pressure that
applied when bitcoin was at three
thousand is like what are you doing
looking at this
the social pressure's working the exact
opposite way or hey
it's 40 000. i need to be looking at
this today but why weren't we already
paying attention to this
basically um and people also
go ahead mike yeah yeah i was just gonna
say people don't want to be left out
right so you got to keep up with
performance if you think that uh
everyone is piling into bitcoin
and that's going to drive huge returns
you know you can't be the odd doc left
out
pomp we spoke with a a portfolio manager
at an endowment
a few weeks ago and basically what he
described is
every single fund manager is looking at
this right now doesn't mean they're
buying
every fund manager at least has to look
at this most of them want to
to allocate a small amount right i don't
know a few basis points maybe one
percent
if they want to invest what's happening
is
they want to invest they have an
investment mandate that says that they
can't
invest right now so what they're doing
is putting it on their personal
inside their personal portfolios so now
you've got these these hedge fund
managers
endowment managers rias financial
advisors
who manage most of the money in the
world
they are they have a mandate that says
that they can't invest through their
fund
they still love bitcoin they invest
personally
now there's an incentive for them
right the beauty of bitcoin is as soon
as you buy it there's an incentive
to make this thing go higher just like
any other asset and so now
you've got the portfolio managers of the
largest asset managers in the world
they might not own it on their funds
portfolio but they own it inside their
personal personal portfolio
yeah well and i think we're just at a
point now where like everyone realizes
frankly what
most of bitcoin's been saying for a
while this is a necessity this isn't uh
a privilege this is a necessity you have
to have this in your portfolio it is the
single greatest protector of
uh purchasing power and it's the only
asset in the world that can protect you
against the chaos
uh in the traditional world yet still
provides you asymmetric opportunities
uh similar to a venture style investment
it's literally like the apex predator of
financial markets
and i think that that sounded nuts at 3
000
that sounded interesting at 20. it
sounds pretty damn smart at 40
right but the same comment it's just
literally the price
almost like opens people's eyes uh and
change their opinion
i'll tell you though i think price is
amazing what's going to be so there's
there's bitcoin the asset and bitcoin
the network right
and bitcoin the network as a as a
payment settlement network
is arguably more interesting than the
asset the asset can get
the asset bitcoin the asset will get
bigger than gold right at some point
they'll be the flipping and it passes
gold
that's really interesting bitcoin the
settlement
layer and the network will become
magnitudes
larger than the asset right and and
that's interesting because
it that really globalizes the world and
actually really helps
the asset helps people protect against
inflation things like that
the the the settlement network and what
guys like jack mallors i think you might
have invested in strike
what what they're working on is is is
just unbelievable
and that's arguably you know for any
investors who are looking at this
don't just look at bitcoin the asset but
look at look at bitcoin in its whole
as a settlement layer yeah absolutely
good mike no i was gonna the interesting
thing about bitcoin too
and honestly if you look at something
like stable coins is it's kind of just a
good product
like the product works you know it's
kind of a similar thing when people
point at
elon musk who just became the richest
guy in the world uh surpassed
me me meme lord meme lord musk
meme lord musk uh as we can look we'll
call him
but you know when people point at tesla
it's kind of like at the end of the day
the guy made an amazing product and when
you look at something like spacex
the guy pulled it off right and it's the
same thing with bitcoin
you can say all you want this price
seems funny and in yada yada
but at the end of the day the technology
works better than the existing financial
system you can literally send money
anywhere in the world and it'll settle
instantaneously
with no middleman it is wha i actually
recently had an experience
trying to help someone open a coin base
and then a brokerage account
the ease of opening a coin base is like
click click click you're done and a
brokerage account takes 30 minutes to do
and multiple approvals
it's a nightmare working with the with
the existing financial system so
look you can look at price but at the
end of the day it is just
kind of a better product than what
exists out there
yeah i uh obviously i agree
what are the things that you guys are
looking forward to in 2021
uh in terms of obviously once you get
this launched uh either milestones for
the industry or milestones for
uh block works
yeah i think uh i mean for block works
but we're really just dead set focused
on we serve one audience
right which is the institutional
audience so i think we've done a great
job building a brand
so far uh in terms of the events and
kind of the
podcasts and that's what we're known for
but really what we're doing this year
we're building that editorial kind of
brand uh
right and onboarding a whole like the
mission statement of what we're doing is
we're trying to talk to directly to this
whole new group of people that are
coming in um in terms of things
that i think i'm looking forward to in
the space uh over the coming year
um just keeping on what's what's
happening right now
as more and more people get into the
space not only is exciting because
obviously uh you know the price of
bitcoin and stuff like that
but you just get more diversity of
thought and opinion and you kind of
build out the infrastructure and
everything just feels
more real you know um so i think it just
just watching as more and more people
come into the space build good products
build successful products
figure out business models just advance
the overall space in general all that
stuff is really really exciting
i think there's about to be a huge
hiring spree i mean the best part of
block works is hiring
people who don't own bitcoin and having
them buy their first bitcoin right and
is that a requirement
uh now it certainly is now and uh
but no i think uh i think the four
biggest things i i'm looking forward to
four things outside of block works right
block works looking forward to growing
revenue and the team's going to
double in size again and all of our
metrics that we look at are going to
grow
but i think there are four themes to
look at
in 2021 the four main bitcoin themes are
going to be
one corporates are going to invest one
percent of their cash into bitcoin
every corporate is going to be looking
at this and just like a lot of funds
some of them might not do it but
everyone's at least looking to invest
one percent of their cash into bitcoin
the second thing is
funds are going to invest one to five
percent
of their portfolios into bitcoin the
third thing is financial advisors and
rias are going to start recommending
bitcoin
i think uh and the fourth thing is i
think the m a space and acquisitions
are gonna really heat up now that
traditional companies want
bitcoin customers so you can sure as
hell believe i know you're a
big investor in block five block five's
have an absolute tear right now
how many customers do they have you know
i'm assuming block file will end up
going public at some point but you can
sure as hell guarantee jp morgan wants
access to those block five customers
so yeah corporates investing funds
investing financial advisors
recommending bitcoin to clients and and
the m and acquisition space heating up
those are the four big themes
that i think will take place this year
and yeah it'll be pretty damn exciting
to see it play out
yeah absolutely i i would even call call
a shot a little bit and say cause
the other really interesting thing that
just recently happened is that occ
announcement
which basically you know seriously
disrupted
swift right um and there's a lot of
incentive there for
kind of investment banks to get involved
in crypto now the other thing about
banks is that they're just
in the business of gathering assets
right like that's that's what they
really do they're in the
asset gathering business and they're
lending out at a high level so
crypto used to be not very exciting when
it was
two billion or three billion dollar
market cap asset now it's a trillion
dollar asset
and who knows when it's going to stop
right so at some point those banks are
going to say
i need this is a whole new pool of
assets that i want to have
that i want to have access to and
honestly the best way that they're going
to move in there
is to buy existing companies that have
successfully gathered those assets so
far
so the m a spaces i agree with jason
it's a really interesting space to watch
yeah the thing too that uh seems to be
really valuable
is as these companies grow they continue
to hire more and more people
into uh from the legacy financial world
or legacy media
uh or legacy tech companies uh and bring
them into the crypto space it feels like
that's
just only going to accelerate and become
faster bigger uh and more important over
time
yeah and with every single person that
comes in it's another person who owns
bitcoin and once you own bitcoin you're
incentivized to tell more people about
it it's an amazing
it's an amazing system i've got this
goal going on right now i just post on
twitter
get 100 friends to buy bitcoin six days
into the year i'm at 12
right and it's like there's
there are thousands of people like me
who are telling their friends about
bitcoin and so every single 30 year old
jp morgan employee who comes over starts
working at coinbase
they're telling 20 of their old
colleagues at jp morgan about bitcoin so
yeah there's a really great article
by and i think andreessen horowitz put
this out um
like a couple years ago now but
basically it's the idea that kind of
everything
follows price and on these big uptrends
in it this is this is already started
right because what ends up happening is
the price ends up going up the media
ends up covering it
a bunch of eyeballs get on this space
and then a bunch of people end up
moving into the space um so that's a
that's a really exciting thing that you
don't necessarily see reflected but
just purely the amount of human capital
that's going to get dragged into this
space
after this recent run-up that's that's
something that's already in motion
i guarantee that that's already starting
so one way to measure that is is
companies hiring right now but that's
kind of more staffing up in anticipation
for a bull run
but over the next like two or three
years the amount of human capitals
that's going to flow into this space
especially from the like legacy
financial system is
really really interesting yeah and it
also just feels like as
more people come into space uh they're
more experienced they've got
a different skill set uh in some cases
they're more intelligent
right like you just kind of like uh
almost professionalize some of what's
going on
uh but at the same time what's really
important is keeping the
same ethos and the same edginess and the
same kind of
um you know absolute fanatical obsession
that has made bitcoin what it is so it's
almost like you're gonna end up having
both sides of the coin where you've got
kind of a professionalization and
adoption by institutions
at the same time you know jump on
twitter real quick and you'll get told
you know have fun staying poor by
somebody who's literally living anywhere
in the world
and wants to take down the government
like it's very rare that an asset can
kind of
uh walk the line between those two camps
but that feels like what bitcoin is
doing and will continue to do in the
future
it's an entire industry that understands
that the memes the memes are the message
right
how's that higher the chief meme officer
coming along
i have somebody i know you i bet you do
i have many i have many people many
people are sitting there uh they keep
uh keep dming me all this uh this
nonsense but i got one guy who uh he's
working on some other things for me too
but
uh he he is uh fire with the memes
amazing
i may or may not have the 30k meme
sitting in my
uh in in my uh arsenal right now but i
have not released it yet
so if you're recording this it dumped
from 40 down to 37.5
you know just make sure everyone
remembers that uh this is a wild beast
that can't be uh can't be tamed nice
little cell order up at 40.
um all right uh before i let you guys go
uh i have three questions
the first thing is what is the craziest
thing that either of you has seen
in the crypto industry
oh man where do you even start with that
um craziest thing that we've ever seen
in the crypto industry
on a micro level it's i mean this sounds
kind of
i don't want to promote scam stuff but
there are some pretty intelligent
scammers out there like
every day i get hit up in my direct
messages on twitter
uh that's some like you know my son you
know my son just died like can you send
me some bitcoin
i don't want to promote those though so
i won't i won't use that i'll think of a
better one
um but those are i mean i i don't know
if that exists in other industries
um the modern day nigerian nigerian
prince everyone wants to get their hands
on some bitcoin you know
um the craziest thing i've seen
honestly is this isn't gonna feel that
crazy not that bitcoin's ripping so much
and it's becoming the norm but like
just every time i hear about
you know yale's investment manager
bitcoin to me is still i heard about
this thing in 2015 when i was living in
freaking budapest hungary right and so
every time i hear
about yale's portfolio manager
buying bitcoin it it it i don't know if
that'll ever cease to amaze me
i'll be honest with you i've actually
got one here for you i actually think
the craziest thing that happened in
crypto happened
in 2018 or 2019 and it was when those
pensions
invested in morgan creek and took that
risk that's the craziest thing
because if you work at a pension you're
tasked with
handling money for everyday people
and they're so you know conservative and
the incentives are not
there to take the risk so the fact that
they went out on
such a limb and invested you guys are
amazing and more complete you guys abs
but the fact that they went and did that
is the most amazing thing that i've seen
in crypto
it's the least risky thing they could do
probably didn't feel like that at the
time
that that was my point was like hey
y'all want to keep playing this
uh this crazy game go ahead but uh
there's another path
so uh i guess i can say it uh their cost
basis
in the first fund is fifty five hundred
dollars not too shabby my friend not too
fast
yeah nice little 10xer they're doing
just fine
um all right the two questions ask
everybody and then you guys get to ask
me a question
uh what is the most important book
you've each read
i think for me actually jason introduced
me so you're about to get a two for here
jason but i think the ascent of money
was actually one of the most interesting
ones and i i don't come from a
background in finance
at all like i like jason that i was a
classics major in school
classic psychology and learning about
what money is and how it has evolved and
how things like credit
have evolved um were really really
instructive and interesting to me and i
think getting that full history was
really what gave me context
honestly for my interest in krypton
bitcoin so i'd say the ascent of money
it's one of my favorites
for me i got two answers one is the one
to make me sound sophisticated it's the
book i'm reading right now because i'm a
history nerd it's
the team of rivals about lincoln but
that's the one to make me sound more
sophisticated than i am
honestly i mean it's almost like a
little embarrassing to say but the one
the books that chain it's a series of
books that changed my life when i was
18.
um it's four exactly that's a seven-part
series i did love that one
but no it's it's it it's a book called
think and grow rich
there's a book called rich dad poor dad
it's a book called richest man in
babylon
and there's a book called um it's a dale
carnegie book how to win friends and
influence people
and i probably read all four of those
books
at least 10 times in college and
i mean i was still [ __ ] in college
but i felt like i had a different
mindset than people
because of these four books um and that
totally changed like reading
rich dad poor dad i was like i'm gonna
be an entrepreneur i'm never i'm never
working for the man i'm not doing the
nine-to-five game
and so yeah think and grow rich how to
win friends and influence people rich
dad poor dad and
richest man babylon as cheesy as those
might sound
those are the three books i read when i
was 20 years old to change my life so
uh aliens how much do both of you
believe
nope 100
not only do i believe in aliens i think
there is a really good chance
that they are already here i don't know
if you guys saw this article that came
out about this israeli guy who was in
the military
for like 30 years and he just came out
and he was like look man i've done my
whole thing
i've built this respected career i've
worked in the government i've worked in
academics
i never said this before because i was
afraid of being called a crackpot but
now i'm old
aliens exist there's a galactic
federation
and there's it's straight up humanity is
not
and you know honestly i think everyone's
allowed one conspiracy thing that
they're allowed to believe in
and this is mine and i i fully it's not
a conspiracy it's science
yeah i agree i'm right i'm right there
with you jason
no what why not
i was in the room the first time you
asked this question you think i'm crazy
enough to say no i just want to see
your response of course aliens exist i
took a 10-day trip to
cairo egypt two years ago by myself
10-day trip
i saw those pyramids of egypt once you
see those things aliens they're a lock
they're they exist you think the aliens
built the pyramids
absolutely yeah man i don't know about
that
absolutely i didn't sign up for that you
haven't seen those things i didn't sign
up for that
those things are like geometrically down
to the inch
miles apart and they're to the inch at a
90 degree angle
i mean i mean i'm jewish i know the jews
are like good at building those things
when they're slaves but
like you don't know you don't know
if if uh aliens are real where do you
think the most likely place that they
are
area 51 i got a wild theory
all right let's hear your theory before
we answer in the ocean
nobody's going down there yeah except
for those fish that have the 12 foot
rods
hanging out with the little light bulb
that is but like but they can't talk
like
nobody's going down there so like how do
we know that they're just not chilling
in the ocean
that's fact can't verify
can't verify i'm just saying just
oh this is not my question i'm not using
my question on this one
all right what are you gonna ask i was
gonna say would you rather go to the
bottom of the ocean or
to the moon not to the moon well we're
going to the moon all together anyways
but
that's a lamb
all right what questions you guys got
for me
i got a question if bitcoin didn't exist
in this whole space
you've always said since the day i met
you you you're you're a tech investor
and that bitcoin's just some of the most
interesting technology in the world
you're not a bitcoin investor you're a
tech investor if
bitcoin didn't exist but you had to
dedicate yourself to one
space whether it be biotech psychedelics
and uh you know mushrooms and things
like that
uh self-driving cars what what one space
would you dedicate the next decade of
your life to
uh just early stage tech investing like
if you had to get more specific than
that though
yeah so like i i think that people think
of that as oh that's just like investing
on
cross i think of it as uh it's one very
very specific skill which is you're
actually investing
in people and uh it doesn't matter what
they're
worried about it's more psychology i
think than anything else
and so the way that i think about it is
like finding the world's most
interesting people who have a higher
probability of success
going after like a massive market right
and so like
those markets like by definition there
can't just be
20 people who all win one market so it's
actually like you have to like cut it a
different way
and it's just at the earliest stages
there's a lot of people who are really
good
series b series c investors a lot of
people who are good series a investors
but like i kind of think that it's a
little bit uh
different than even cheating to some
degree to wait till it's a series b
company and be like oh this one i think
is gonna win like yeah it's working
already and sure they can mess it up but
like
you have data you have all this stuff
but it takes an absolute
you know just a crazy person to
sit down with somebody and they say i'm
gonna go build
a billion dollar business and for you to
say like cool
i believe you here's you know a hundred
thousand dollars just 250 000
so let's go do it and it also takes a
crazy person
to be the person who sits down saying
like you know i'm gonna go build a
billion dollar company from scratch
and so like i just genuinely enjoy
meeting those people and having those
conversations um
and i've now invested in
the seed round of four yeah i think four
companies are a billion dollars or more
uh and so like when you start to get a
couple of those data points
you start to realize like the people are
the exact same
from a like a structure standpoint uh
and the way that they think they're
going after different industries they're
all facing different challenges
but i think that like almost like the
science of identifying those people and
studying how to do that
uh is fascinating to me and so like
luckily i get to do bitcoin
and that but if bitcoin didn't exist
like that would be the obsession that i
have
can i get a follow-up question there
which would be sure you said they all
kind of look alike right
four companies what's what's one trait
i'm sure there are a few different
traits but what's
one trait of the some of the founders of
these companies
um i think that there is
uh a critical thinking and problem
solving trait
that usually goes undiscussed like
everyone was talking about like
oh they're smart or oh they're good at
hiring or they're good storytellers like
yeah duh you have to be able to do all
that stuff but at the end of the day
it's just this like
uh deep seated um kind of like
fire of when i see a problem i want to
solve it
when i see another problem i want to
solve it and i'm constantly on offense
when i see problems rather than defense
a lot of people when a problem pops up
they go oh i don't want to
like they go away there's a hard
conversation
they don't want to have it if there's an
issue they would
hope that somebody else steps in and
solves it before they have to the best
founders that i know
who've built the most successful
companies if something happens they
immediately attack and they just
what's the problem what what's the
information that we have how do we make
a good decision here who's responsible
for owning this in the future
like go and they say that over and over
and over again all day long
and when you're building a company from
scratch into a multi-billion dollar
business like
it's just a series of solving problems
and making sound decisions
so you have to enjoy the problem solving
just as much as you do
making sound decisions um and i think we
always focus on like oh this person you
know smart
successful yada yada whatever but like
the problem solving piece
is like that's where you roll up your
sleeves and really do the work and so
the best founders like they
really enjoy doing that stuff even
though it might not be fun at all times
because the problems suck or they're
unexpected or it's on vacation
or holiday or whatever um but just they
just have this like obsession with
getting the problem solved and keep
marching forward that's good yeah
all right palm i've got i've got one
question for you what is
the best investment you've ever made
and i don't mean which one did you make
the most money on
uh that's not what i'm asking and wide
ranging it could be
a founder that you invested in all right
planet by far oh oh that is
that is great i think it's just um
when you think about uh investing
and planning i talked about this like
very early on in our relationship i said
look there's like basically two paths
that
lead people to uh having a successful
marriage and kind of partnership for
like many years
one is uh you either meet somebody young
and you essentially re-invent yourself
and they reinvent themselves over and
over and over again for literally
yeah let's say you meet if you're in a
high school for example you meet when
you're
16 17 18 years old and then basically
you've got to transition from like okay
we were in high school so now we're like
in college together okay we survived
that and thrive then we gotta go from
college to
like early professional life then we
gotta get to like mid to late twenties
then you gotta get like okay now i wanna
have a family
right then you get to like oh now we're
like really doing well professionally
then it's like okay like now our kids
have gone off to college like
there's so many different almost acts to
that maturation process
and so the odds that you're going to
meet somebody like really early in life
and successfully
make a lot of those transitions
especially the earliest ones it's just
really small
like the sample size you're pulling from
is small it's like who do they go to
high school like
yeah sure maybe but like that's a really
really difficult thing
or the second thing is people basically
go on their own paths and then
eventually they meet at some point
usually kind of late 20s early 30s maybe
even into their 40s
and when they meet it's like hey i've
already had to
get some sort of traction in my life in
certain aspects
uh without you but now like all of these
future transitions like that's something
that i think we can do together
and so like i was in the camp of like
i am never gonna get married like people
say that
i was like i'm never going to get
married why would you
ever get married that sounds like the
dumbest thing in the world
like what you mean that like now you
have to make decisions
and like somebody else can say like i
don't want to do that and you might have
to listen
nah if i want to go party i'm going to
go party if i don't eat mcdonald's i
want to eat mcdonald's
if i don't want to do anything today i'm
not going to do anything that's my
approach to life
and when i met paulina uh it was like
almost immediately we were just like
all right i think that like maybe i'm
not gonna
just do whatever i want for the rest of
my life and so to me it's just like
that investment of like time and like
really open-mindedness i think
has been the best investment because
what you begin to realize is like
it's hard to grow as an individual by
yourself like you only have the
perspective of the world that you have
and so like
whether it's planet like looking over my
shoulder being like eh i wouldn't tweet
that like that's
you're not like thinking about this
other thing like you're gonna be an
idiot here
all the way to like me coming up with oh
hey i have to make a really important
decision professionally like let's sit
down and talk about it
like having somebody there that has the
same context that has the same
kind of goals and aspirations
that's like really really valuable and
so i think that people just
underestimate like
that element of it uh and they always
focus on like
what company did i invest in or like you
know where i chose to move to
or whatever but to me like by far that's
been the most impactful thing and like
nothing's even close
that's a great answer that's a great
answer block fight is a distant second
she paid me a lot of money to say
sponsored by the profile yeah
so the episode is not sponsored by the
profile we have no free sponsors you
don't get any advertising unless you pay
so we will not be giving out the read
the profile.com url
in this episode because it's not a paid
sponsorship we'll only be giving up the
url blockworks.co
go get it right now yeah
all right i appreciate you guys coming
on uh blockworks.co
is uh the website you guys should go and
well not youtube
you guys are going to be there anyways
but if you're listening or watching this
you should go check it out
i'm a huge fan of jason and mike uh and
they've been super helpful to me
as all this stuff has gotten built so go
check it out blockworks.com
youtube i will uh talk to you soon we'll
definitely do it again in the future
and uh to end it i've gotta you know
just throw a little jab in there
uh mike your uh zoom name is maria
ipolito
so we'll talk to them that's the name we
try to cut costly